all right Cynthia yes Cynthia where are
you from originally New Jersey what part
South like 30 minutes from Atlantic City
mhm tell me about your childhood growing
up o
um not good um I
am Mexican so I feel in my personal
opinion that the culture is very very
toxic and it's mainly
like focused on the man and like um the
women are attentive to them and no
matter what they do it doesn't matter
because there's food on the table and
you have a roof over your head you have
the nicest cars you know the newest cell
phones the nicest clothes so whatever
happens behind closed doors
just under the rug pretend that you know
life is good so that's basically how my
childhood was this is your father that
you're talking about well yeah my
stepfather stepfather yes I well he
basically raised me since I was an
infant and the funny thing is that I
didn't even know he was my stepfather
until I was like 16 they just I don't
know why I kept that as a secret and
then one day they sat me down they're
like okay we're just going to let you
know that oh he's not your real dad but
now now that it matters because you know
he's still your dad and and to me it
really didn't
because
um I just believe in like nature versus
nurture and like he basically did raise
me you know he taught me everything that
I know today and a lot of things that I
still use today so like you mean Nur
vers versus nature yes so like even
though I'm not his biological kid I feel
like I'm his kid in that way because he
just he raised me yeah he was your dad
yeah my sister's
dad and how was childhood with with that
Dynamic
[Music]
um if you were to ask me that when I was
little I would say oh my childhood's
perfect you know he's a great dad he's a
good guy everyone in town loves him um
he's
Charming he is a good guy in the
daylight you know he's your typical good
guy and at night time I received all of
his
evilness
and basically he started to molest me
when I was 6 years old as early as I can
remember
and it continued all the way up till I
was
18 18 years old
and you you never said anything I did I
said something when I was
16 and I had like a you know a
girlfriend at the time like and I said
something to her and she spoke
to the guidance counselor and then they
made it a big thing and you know right
forly so they called the um
Sheriff I ended up going to the police
barracks in town
and had to tell them everything and I
was there
for 7 hours telling them everything will
happened that that happened and they
arrested
him like an hour of me talking to them
and
then shortly after I had to recant and
tell the detectives you know child
servant is oh it was all a lie like I
was I'm crazy I don't know why I said
those things he's a great guy but it was
all because it I was I had to do it like
I was coed to do it with my whole family
there the rest of the family did it yes
every every single family member was
appalled that I how could I do that to
him you know he's a great guy like
whatever happens you know at Le like you
still have a house you know
so I had
to recant and it was probably one of the
hardest the very hardest moments of my
life because my mother was very upset
with me so I had no support from
anyone no emotional support
no I guess just morally and no one was
there for me how does that make you feel
as a little
kid 16 years old right yeah but it made
me feel I guess what they made made me
feel my entire life I started to believe
like because they would always say like
I'm crazy cuz I was the I was very like
um hyper as a kid like very bad like
just so they were just like oh she's
crazy and then when my mental illness
started kicking like anxiety and you
know depression stuff like that they're
like oh see she's crazy you know she's
making all this up so shortly after he
got arrested he was in jail for 6 months
and in those 6 months I became very
depressed because now my entire Dynamic
changed like my entire life was
completely different he was arrested for
what
um I guess for rape like sexual abuse
like they got him and I thought that
this was it for me like I was free but
when I started to
recant um they believed me and let him
go and he came back to the
house I guess he was in jail for like
six 7 months and he came back to jail
like he came back home from jail just to
be clear the time he spent in jail was
not your case or it was your case no it
was my case it was your case he yeah he
got arrested because I yeah SP then oh
you recanted later I recanted like the
next few days because my family was in
distraught you think they would have let
him free
then what do you mean my family no
the he would have been he wouldn't have
gone to jail for 6 months if if you
recanted after a few days yeah I don't
know why the process was just too long
like we kept having to go to court and I
um had to talk to the detectives like
and his lawyers like I made it all up
and I guess they believed that more than
they believed my story because when I
was at the police barracks giving my
interview I was there for like 7 hours
and everyone believed me everyone was
like this we believe you like this story
is crazy like you have all the details
like we we know you're not making this
up but I guess when I recanted they
believe that more probably because they
just let him go well I think there's a
huge hole when the victim is recanting
it just kind of puts a giant hole in
this in the case yes
mhm hard to prosecute yes especially
because all he had a lot of good
statements from other people like he's a
good guy he he's not capable of this
like there's no
away so so what happened to you after
that when he came
back um everything was different for a
good three months I was everything was
peaceful and when he came back we sat
down and spoke just me and him and he
was just like I'm a changed man I'm a
man of the Lord I read the Bible in jail
I did all these like Bible studies in
jail and
I'm a changed man um I'm so sorry for
what I did to you and he was crying so
like I believed him and in those moments
I was like wow like I have a dad now
like I finally have a dad like all these
years I had this monster and now I have
a dad so I believed him that the abuse
was going to be over and but then he
like would sneak in little things in
there by saying oh well now things are
going to be different so you're not
going to be able to go out as much you
know I'm not going to be able to provide
things for you as much but I feel like
that was punishment you know him
punishing me
for letting out his
secret
so it was a good three months that went
by that nothing happened everything was
great like no late night things
and we ended up getting to a fight and
it was just a dumb fight about like my
cat and and because of these few months
of me feeling free and
safe I got like confident
and we started to argue
and he was never aggressive he's not an
aggressive man he's very calm and he
came up to me because I was talking back
to him and he stood in front of me and I
was sitting down and he stood in front
of me to intimidate me for talking back
and I stood up and as soon as I stood up
he slapped me and that was the first
time he's ever laid hands on me put int
like and when he slapped me I saw red
and I
felt everything that needed to come out
since I was a little kid come out and I
just started punching him and just not
like I couldn't stop I just kept wailing
on him and to this day that's my
greatest achievement it was the best
thing that ever happened to me like
and I just
remember like the physical like my
Knuckles hit in his face and it felt
great how yeah tell me about the feeling
of
physically be beating up somebody who's
been doing this to you for years oh my
God it was I mean at this point I was
probably 17 now so like I feel like you
know badass teenager taking on my dad
like but obviously he's very strong so
um he stopped me like he let I think he
let me he let me get a few punches in
because there's no way that he would
just sit there or just stand there he's
probably a bigger guy I got a few
punches in and my mom stepped in and my
sister ran crying hid in her
room and when my mom stepped in between
us going like this trying to stop the
fight I remember looking at him saying
watch like watch what's going to happen
now like I got you like the ball's in my
court
now and and he just looked at me in
fear and I don't know what I meant by
that by saying watch like I think I
meant like I'm going to get you back now
like
I'm
but shortly after that oh yeah we didn't
talk I didn't talk to him for a few
months after that like I felt like I
took my freedom back
and ignored him literally ignored him
for months he would try to talk to me I
would pretend he's not there that's a
good trait that my mother gave me to
ignore and give you the silent tratment
and make you feel like you're not in the
room which is a very toxic thing that
I'm still learning to you know in
therapy
but I started to feel bad that I was
ignoring him and not talking to him and
he would cry and he would just say oh I
just missed my girl you know I just miss
my daughter I don't I don't like that
we're I don't like us fighting I hated
that we did you
know and then one night he just came in
my room as if nothing ever
happened and I just
[Music]
remember him taking my pants off and
then the guilt that I had
of um avoiding him and ignoring him and
hurting his
feelings influenced my decision to just
lay down and just not do anything and
that's the first time or that's when now
the rape continued again when he came
back from jail were you in some way
cooperating with what he was
doing um no at that point I was just in
a dissociation State of Mind
where I would just lay there and just
um because I didn't want him to be
upset
and also because him being
upset the next
day he would make me feel like I did
something wrong like I remember plenty
of nights when I was you know younger
where I would say no
like just leave me alone like no and he
would respect that and he would just
walk away but then the next
day I was being punished like if I
needed new shoes he'd be like No And
this man has money like he has a good
job and he would just say no like you
don't deserve that or if I needed or if
I needed to go out or needed to do
something or k can you take me here he
would be like no I'm sure it's a
complicated Dynamic yeah so
then I was trained to just do as he says
because then I obviously learned that if
I were to do what he said then it would
go good for me the next day so I was
able to
sacrifice 10 to 20 20 minutes every
night to have a good day the next
day
so that was
basically 13 years of
that all the time and you got away at
what
age um 19 I met someone and I told her
everything that happened and she was
appalled and she's
like you're not living there anymore
and
um soon as I told her everything the
next day
she called her dad her cousins her
siblings and we're like we're getting
sin out of here and they packed up his
truck with my stuff you know from my
childhood bedroom like a bed dresser and
clothes and took me out of the house and
I never went back and she basically
saved me from the dysfunction continuing
because who knows where I would be if
that were to continue you know in my
adult ears because like I said being in
that
culture you don't talk about it and no
even though people know as long as you
have a smile on my face which I'm sure
you can see that I've
mastered you can just continue to have
good life you know and act like nothing
ever happen no matter what's happening
behind closes doors just don't talk
about it just keep in the closet yeah
just don't talk about it because if you
talk about it then it's an inconvenience
and you're ruining the day you're
ruining the mood and everyone's having a
good day and you decided you want to
talk about something that's detrimental
to you and that's happening to you like
how could you like how can you ruin my
day for talking about something that
happened to you so I learned that very
very well and I learned the smile
technique and I've learned that if you
just smile no one will ask you it's
wrong so then therefore you don't have
to come up with a lie you know you don't
have to be like oh well I'm feeling this
and I'm feeling that and then you're
forced to
just a open up and then B if someone has
nothing to say to you then you're just
like okay well I shouldn't have said
anything so if you just smile then no
one asks you any questions then you know
you just keep it moving and in hindsight
now how old are you now 29 you're 29 so
you can look back at how everything went
down would you have handled it
differently
now oh yeah yeah I would have not
recanted I would have
um even though that meant my whole
family being upset with me which it
didn't do me any good because I still
don't have any contact with them
um but I mean given the circumstances
that I was you know and I don't blame my
inner child for that but if I could I
would not recant I would take that back
and just stay on my ground and let him
rot in jail because from what I heard
from the prosecutors when I was 16 that
he was going to get um lengthy service
like a u s he was going to serve a long
time sentence yes a long long time and I
was good with that I was happy with that
even though that me I was going to lose
my dad you know the good part of him
during the day I was going to lose that
I was okay because then I was no longer
going to experience what happened at
night so I was okay with that but that's
the only thing I would take back have
You' been seeing a therapist yes yeah
she's amazing um in Pittsburgh because I
live in Pittsburgh right now so I'm
seeing a therapist
she is a trauma therapist and we do EMDR
which I'm sure you've heard of
mhm and it's the best this eye eye
movement yes it's the best and worst
tell tell the viewers who don't know
what EMDR is um it is shameful but I
don't know what it stands for I know
it's like um eye movement realization
something you basically either look at
some a light moving back and
forth or you listen to sounds on either
ear back and forth and it's supposed to
stimulate bilaterally your brain and
help you you know unlock memories
and basically like bring your memories
that are from the back that you have
stored bring them to the front and deal
with them because from what I've
gathered a memory is supposed to feel
like a memory not it's not supposed to
feel like it just happened yesterday and
if it just happened yesterday then you
need to work on it and I want to say
like 70% of my memories and my trauma
feel like Memories now because of my
therapist and she's great and she
props you know props to her for dealing
with me but she is probably one of the
reasons why I'm still here because she's
not giving up on me and she's just
like you know we got to get through this
like this isn't this isn't the end of
the road for you
and so yeah I'm still doing that and I'm
pretty sure I'm probably going to do you
know be in therapy for the rest of my
life how often would it go on with your
dad there's seven days in a week week
probably half like three three times a
week you
know um more less depending on his mood
depending
on anything if he had a bad day if if he
had a good day he would leave me alone
um and how are things now with him and
your
family I don't have any contact with him
whatsoever my he still lives at home
with my sibling and my mother you were
the only one that he would do this to
apparently and
I've um grilled my sister and she swears
up and down that didn't happen to
her and I want to believe that I want to
believe that because it makes me feel
good to know
that she's his real daughter but then
again when when
like
um Common Sense kicks in so was I when I
was an infant all the way up to you know
to he raised me
but he would also make comments about
like when I remember being little and
asking him
like is my sister getting this too and
he would just say to me like no like
it's just you like you know you're my
special girl and I believed it and I
hope that it's true
so it was just
me how do you think
this has impacted your adult life oh my
god
um a lot and it's going to for the rest
of my life and I have two step two step
kids now who are girls
and when I first met them they were two
and six and as they you know grew
throughout the
years I would just find myself
comparing them to my childhood and
looking at them and being
like wow like they are never going to
experience this pain and it's such a
beautiful thing
to be a part of to know that these two
human beings are never going to hurt the
way that I hurt and they're never going
to experience pain in the way that I did
maybe you know obviously other ways but
like this way I have the full me you
know and my partner have the full
control of knowing that they are never
going to hurt like this they're never
going to know what this is and to me
that's like that keeps me going to know
that I can provide light you know for
two innocent souls and I mean they're
obviously one of the biggest reasons why
I'm so here because I it it like gives
me Faith in humanity you know seeing to
beautiful kids just grow and know like
this Darkness they're never going to
know what it is and your partner is a
female yes do you think that's because
of what you went through with your dad
that's funny that you say that because I
just had a few therapy sessions like in
the last couple weeks
about you know coming to the to the
realization like is this why I'm with
I'm with a woman because of what
happened to me because you know growing
up you would feel safer yeah and growing
up in my teen years um I was active with
men and you know I am attracted to men I
know I you know they're beautiful
creatures just as much as females are
but I don't feel you know safe with them
like not safe just comfortable and I
just don't trust anyone so I don't I
wouldn't put anything past anyone
especially
males so for me it is more about like a
a safety thing to be with a woman to
know that
they're not going to hurtt me in that
way and I just I don't want to I don't
want to try it with the man to see how
it is just because I just I'd rather not
open that door it's
understandable but I mean I find him
attractive like I you know I can see a
guy and be like he's hot but that's it
just keep it moving yeah I mean the
right guy maybe one day but if you're
happy now you're happy now I'm happy now
and I I don't see that as an opportunity
unless something were to happen you know
God forbid something were happen because
I am very happy with my wife she is an
amazing woman
and without her I wouldn't not only
physically be here but like I wouldn't
be right here and she encourages me
every single day to just keep it moving
and that my trauma does not define who I
am and it's
not who I am it's what I'm going to go
through for the rest of my life but it
it's not me
and it's not to say you know
like with trauma victims like when they
boast about them being survivors like
good like I'm glad that that's how you
feel but to me I don't want to look at
it like um oh something bad happened to
me poor me and here I am now if anything
like everything that I've went through
taught me a lot and obviously like made
me who I am today so it's just a shitty
road that I went on and you know I was
fortunate
to detour find M on road find my own
peace and deal with the trauma even
seems it seems like you're very able to
speak about it calmly and that's because
of my new therapist now yeah well I
didn't have to give you a tissue I
didn't have to no because yeah like I
said she validates me a lot and I mean
there's obviously moments where I go
into therapy and I'm a wreck and I'm
crying
and I I feel and look like my dog just
died and that's just because I'm going
to that's how life is I'm going to have
days where I'm up and I'm good and then
it's going to go back down and then I'm
depressed and I'm sad and I
feel guilt and I feel shame and those
are the the two big things that I feel
every single day is guilt and shame and
that's why I'm in therapy because I
don't want to feel those things but I
feel a lot
of um shame knowing that I was a
teenager you know a woman and I was
allowing these things to happen to me
but I keep um you know just like
replaying my therapist words like you
weren't allowing it just it's all you
knew you know that was your Norm that
was you were a kid yeah like that that's
how you were that's how your brain was
trained you know
because your crucial moments of your
life when you're a kid your brain is
developing mine was developing to know
that this is this is normal you know
this happens and I remember like being a
teen teenager and wondering like is this
happening to my friends like are my
cousins going through this like hm I
wonder if that's happening with them and
like because I thought it was just so
normal I thought I thought it was
something that you do do just because of
how he made it seem and he made it feel
like oh I love you you're my kid like
this is just another way to me showing
you how I love you and I mean I believed
it I thought that that was
love for a very long
time what advice would you give to
somebody who Latino or otherwise that be
going through something like this
Latinos
um it's hard with Latinos
because they're stuck in their cultural
ways
and but if it means that you are going
to become the black sheep and you are
looked at as the bad one and the crazy
one just do it anyways because at the
end of the day at the end at the end
there is that light at that tunnel and
it's going to be a long shitty tunnel
and it's going to hurt and it's going to
suck and people are going to be upset
with you and they're going to call you
names they're going and they're going to
blame you for ruining the family Dynamic
but at the end of the day like this is
your life you know like you have to live
for you you can't live for your mom or
your grandma or your aunts or your
uncles like you have to live for you and
even though I have a shitty relationship
with my mother who I
don't we talk every now and then because
of my guilt but she married him this
year after everything after all of this
and decided to just marry him because
she loves him and he's a good
guy and that's the biggest slap in the
face to me that was the biggest is
because one thing you know to turn your
back on me and to not choose me and not
you know not protect me not be there for
me you know yeah it sucks and but I'm
coping with it you know I was going to
therapy I was trying to find a middle
ground with having a relationship with
my mother and knowing that she did all
these things to me as
well but now her doing this it just
like
like I feel like my puzzle was almost
complete she just went like this to it
so I feel like now I'm back to square
one knowing that she was also abusive
like to me like realizing a lot of the
things that
she put me through when I was a kid was
also abused but I never looked at it
like that because he was the bad one
like he was the monster so now I'm
unpacking a whole new other yeah but
allowing it to allowing your partner to
have to do this to your kid
yep mhm she's almost as guilty as he is
or she probably is as guilty as he is if
not she's a little bit more maybe just
you know and that's what
I'm processing now and realizing and
that's a whole another wave of emotions
and feelings
and depression and anxiety and then
knowing like if the two most important
people that were supposed to love you
and protect you hurt you there's no way
in hell that your partner's going to
love you you know and that's where these
are where all the abandonment issues
come in and the trust issues and you
know neglect to
know Mom and Dad hurt
you my wife my wife can't love me
there's no way you know my kids can't
love me there's no way in hell but
that's just you know the darkness and
the trauma talking to you and it's a
bottle every day but I feel like
today now that I'm going to survive this
battle and I think I'm doing pretty good
I think so I think so too Cynthia thank
you so much for sharing your story of
course I wish you all the luck in the
world thank you for having me you are
changing lives because you popped up on
my um YouTube page a few years ago I was
like what is this man doing you know but
you're doing a service to
humanity so thank you for having me all
right
thanks